[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar expanded carrier screening
clinical research with ion torrent
carrier seek ecs
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific to learn
more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
in addition to asking questions we
encourage you to participate in two poll
questions at the end of the speaker
presentation
click on your answer when the poll
questions are displayed
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
bruno kopersky is currently the head of
ivf at igenomics brazil he has worked
more than nine years in the field of
reproductive genetics in his previous
experience he has worked in major
laboratories in brazil
bruno has experience in pre-implantation
genetic diagnosis pgd pgt
m and pgtsr
and pre-implantation genetic screening
pgs pgta
carrier screening dna sequencing and
molecular biology he participated in the
implementation of different laboratories
in brazil
united states mexico and spain
bruno you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone
thank you for the introduction so my
name is bruno kopreski and currently i'm
the head of ivs ivf here at igenomics in
brazil
and today we are going to talk about the
expanded care screening clinical
research with iron torrent terror sex
acs
first of all uh we have to talk about
the disclaimers
the thermofishing scientific and its
affiliates are not endorsing
recommending or promoting any use of
application
of thermospecial scientific products
presented by third parties during this
seminar
information and materials presented or
provided by third parties are provided
as in and without warrant of any kind
including regarding intellectual proper
properties rights and reported results
party presenting image text and material
represents they have the right to do so
so today we're gonna have three learning
objectives so the first one will be what
is a carrier screening and how
is it used
the second of it will be expectation for
nhs basic care screening clinical
research and the last but not least the
best practice for implementation and
validation of the jairosex ecs
so let's get started
what is the carrier screening and how
we can use it how easy it uses the first
thing that we have to know is what is
the genetic disorder so this is so
important for us so a genetic disorder
is a disease
caused in whole or in part by a change
in the dna sequence
away from the normal sequencing so
we call it a gene a change in the dna
sequence when we have a change in a pair
base when we have a change from a to t
or say for instance when we have a
deletion of 5 or 10 fair basis
this is all we can call a change in the
dna sequence
the genetic disorders can be caused by
those five types
of
different parts of uh genetic uh
mutations
the first of one we call it a monogenic
or single gene disorder
this is the disease that we have one
mutation in only one gene and
we have uh unfortunately a disease
the second one is when we have
the multi-factor inheritance disorder
so we must have
mutation in multiple genes
or we can call it polygenic
to unfortunately have the disease
the third uh
genetic disorder we can call it when we
have the combination of genetic
mutations in the
environmental factors say for instance
when we have the autism that we have
gene mutations of genetic mutations and
unfold unfortunately also the
environmental factors to
uh unfortunately has the disease
of course we also have alterations in
the mitochondrial dna then we can call
it the mitochondrial absorber and this
is so important because the
mitochondrial disorder we have only uh
we can only
have this disease when it's passed by
our mothers because we have all the
mitochondria that we have in our body we
receive it from our mothers
and of course
when we have a chromosomal disorder that
we have
a change in the number or the structure
of an entire chromosome
the chromosome is the structure that
carries
all of our genes
say for instance the chromosomal
disorder that we talk we can call it the
down syndrome that is unfortunately when
we have three copies of the chromosome
21
so
to continue what is the single gene
disorder
we call it a single gene disorder is a
hair hereditary disorder that is caused
by a presence of a mutation or mutations
in a particular regime
these diseases
are rare interference but according to
the data from the world health
organization
the global prevalence of this illness is
10 in 1 000 new war in fact
there are estimated that taking together
indicate that this illness represents 20
percent
of the causes of infinite mortality in
developing countries
and
that they are behind
eighteen percent of the intervention in
padriatic hospital
this is why is so important
to
screen
all these types of mutations when we are
thinking about to have pregnancy
so
how can we classify the single gene
disorders
so
we have three different types of
classification for this uh single gene
disorders
so
uh of course we can uh have this
difference according to their
inheritance better
so the first one we call it a dominant
disease
those disease involves the damage or a
mutation in only one gene copy
so as we can see in this image
when a person does not have the
condition
we call it a non-carrier
but unfortunately when a person has a
mutation in this type of gene
we can call it affected
we just need
only one mutation in only one gene copy
to have the condition
we have
to be aware that of course we do have
two gene copies for every single gene
that we have
the second classification that we have
for single gene disorders we call it
recessive disease
that include or occur due to the damage
in both copy of the genes so as we can
see it a person that does not have the
condition we call it non-carrier
but if a person has
just
one mutation in just one gene copy we
call it a carrier
but if a person receives
a mutation from his part his father and
his mother
this person will have two
mutations in the two gene copies and
unfortunately has the condition and we
call it
affected
and the third category that we classify
the single gene disorders we call it
x-linked diseases
there are monogenic disorders that are
linked
to defective genes on the x chromosome
and this is important to tell you that
all the men's
has
one x chromosome and one y chromosome
and all the women have
two x chromosomes
normally
so if we talk that a man does not have
the condition
in this x chromosome we don't have any
mutation
but
if we can talk that a woman
is a carrier for that disease
it means
that
in one of the chromosomes x in this gene
she has a
and unfortunately it can pass by
the descendants
if unfortunately this woman that which
we call it a carrier
pass on the x mutated to
see up to a male child
unfortunately
this male will have disease because it
only has
one x
so uh what we can call about the
frequency for this single genes disorder
we can see it right now
in our literature that we have that 82
percent of individuals are carrier for
at least
one genetic condition
and
have a chance of passing it to their
children
even if cells are healthy
every person has an average of two
genetic mutations
and unfortunately
five percent of couples carries the same
mutation
and there are
a huge problem
to
uh to screen it
and to test it those persons to
check if unfortunately they do
carry the same mutation or mutations in
the same gene and unfortunately
their children can have a 25
to
become affected of course we are talking
about the recessive
disorders
most carriers of genetic mutation
don't have a family history of this
disorder and this is so important so
because generally parents only realize
they are carriers of a serious genetic
disorders after unfortunately an
affected child is born
for these reasons if both parents carry
a mutation in the same gene
then we will be at much higher risk of
having an affected child
and we can talk this at this risk it
will be 25
this is why it is
so important
to think about the carer screening in
those type of patients
in this slide
we have uh we can see that the improved
knowledge on the interpretation of
genetic variations in our genome it is
so important for all the testing that we
are going to perform it
today and from
five or ten years from now
of course we all know that we live in a
multi-ethnic society it is so important
to have this different uh
genetic the
difference in genetics that we have in
different ethnicities it is so important
for us to realize
what is our
genome our genome like as a society in
this graphic we can see that the the
first uh genome that was sequenced was
sequencing enough in 2001 when we
when it was finished finished the the
human genome project and to
to
sequence
one genome
complete genome it took
days or maybe weeks or years to perform
it
right now with all
the updates that we have in our
sequencers in our bioinformatics and
everything that we have right now we can
sequence a whole genome in less than 48
hours
this is
so important for us to
to be able to
uh provide this type of test for
every single one that we have in our
population
so
what are the recommendations for the
expanded carrier screening gene panel
development and this is so important
because the expanded care screening is
an acceptable strategy for pregnancy and
prenatal care screening provide that
specific criteria for the testing are
met and this is so important that the
this is not bruno saying this is the
acog or the smg talking about the
statements and positions
regarding the expanded carry screen
so all parents who are considering
pregnancy or are already pregnant
regarding of the screening strategy and
ethnicity
should be offered the prayer career
screening for cystic cystic fibrosis and
spinal muscular atrophy
as well as a complete body count and
screening for palestinians and
chemogoblino panties
fragile eggs premutation carry screening
is recommended for women with a family
history of fragile x related disorders
or intellectual disability
suggested of fragile leg syndrome
or women with a personal history of
ovarian insufficiency
additional screening also maybe also may
be indicated based on the family history
or specific ethnicity
additionally screening conditions should
be able to diagnose prenatally and make
effort opportunity for anti-nato
intervention to improve
perinatal outcomes
change to the display delivery
management to optimize newborn and
infant outcomes and education of their
parents about special care needs after
birth
and finally
expanded care screening panels
may include rare conditions
uh for such such disorders the precise
carrier frequency as well as the
proportion of the conditional causing
variance
that can be detected may be unknown
therefore the calculation of residual
risk after negative screening tests may
not be possible for all conditions
and this is so important that for
everyone that is listening to and is
thinking about the terror screening that
expanded carry screening should not
include
autosomal dominant or
adult onset multi-factor
conditions so
when we think about uh expanded carrot
screening where we when we think about
carrot screening uh the test is
recommended in the following case
for a couple
that wants to form a family to know
the risk of transmitting hereditary
disorders to their charge
before an assisted reproductive
treatment then is so important right now
we can see that the united states
uh
around like more than
the majority of persons that are
performing at assisted reproductive
treatment are thinking about the career
screening because of this importance
and of course
it's
important to perform a career screening
before a treatment with donor sperm or
eggs to realize if unfortunately this
donor
has on a condition that
maybe a person has did it also
here i wanted to provide you the
brazilian scenario that we have for care
screening
unfortunately the cherry screening here
in brazil
it's not that long as we have the united
states for it for example
right now we don't have the majority of
persons that are thinking about the
assisted assisted uh reproductive
techniques technicians uh
looking for this type of stuff
so to for you to realize
the estimated carrier frequency for six
cell trade in brazil it's one in 25
in the general population and
it is
one in ten in the afro dissidents
here in brazil
we have the ninth largest astronautic
jewish population in the world
and unfortunately the astronauts two
individuals are at risk to be carriers
for certain autosomal recessive
conditions such as disaster disease
the carrier frequency for
cystic fibrosis is increased in the
individuals of european dissidents
compared to other ancestral groups this
is so important when we talk about the
populations in europe or the populations
in the united states
in the populations of european descent
the carrier frequency is 1 in 25.
european origins make up approximately
60 percent of the general brazilian
population
and entire
78
of the population in the southern region
which means that many brazilians are
increased risk for being carried for
cystic fibrosis for example
and we have this image that uh uh
that i look at out in a in an article
that we we have here in brazil that was
published by the in the literature that
uh
the researchers have asked it to 353
persons if this person have ever heard
about some disorders
and
by unfortunately we have
an
unknown
knowledge
of a lot of genetic diseases say for
instance we have like uh around just
20 percent of knowledge of what is thy
socks
or maybe 20 20 to 25 percent of persons
that knows what is thalassemia
the sexist fibrosis is a disease that
the majority of person here in brazil
knows
around 70 percent but it's not 100
percent of the brazilians that knows
that we have a disease that is called a
cycle fibrosis and this is a disease
that unfortunately caused biogenetic
mutation
so this is the uh this is our part
to become uh
presenters of this knowledge or this
information to
raise awareness
to all the brazilians that we have here
or of course all the people in the world
uh in this other publication that we
have in this world of publication
published in 2021 by kyogre uh
is a doctor here in brazil uh
i'm acquaintance with a huge
researcher
he has provided us
by analyzing samples that were
sequenced
to check to to see the test of uh
accurate screening so
a total of 425
of currency of 351
different variants
was found in a brazilian population
and
47 variants were recruited more than
once
and this is so important
were reported in
278
different genes
for 230
patients
a percentage of 71.9 percent in a cohort
of 30 to 320 patients
for 90 cases or 28.1
no variants were reported
and in the overall they observed an
average of one point three point two
reported variants per patient
and this is so important for us because
right now we have this uh unfortunately
this
this knowledge that we we don't have any
variance that we don't have any genetic
mutation but we can see in this
presentation that more than 70 percent
of the patients
have
a mutation
of course this mutation does not carries
uh or does not uh becomes a disease
we are not talking about that seventy
percent of the person are genetic with a
genetic disease but they're seventy
percent of these populations they're the
terrorists a mutation and can be at risk
if
they choose or
uh unfortunately if their their
partners
has the same mutation or in the same
genes so this is why it's so important
to test the population regarding the
care screening when we're talking about
the
genetic population or to think about all
the diseases that we can uh
not to
this those diseases that we can tell we
can
not pass on to our children so this is
why it is so important
this is the second part of this
presentation when we're going to talk
about the expectation for the ngs based
career screening in clinical research
when we talk about the ngs base carrier
screening we have to talk about the
advances and the decreasing cost of the
ngs
enables
the care screening research across a
border range of the disorders using the
extended care screening gene exams
the next generation sequencing
based
expanded care screening research has
demonstrated the identification more at
risk pregnancy in comparison to care
screening research based on ethnicity
and family history
in my opinion
with my experience
we are able to see when we perform and
we compare
the iron tore and terrorist cleaning
that expanded keras cream to other
panels that we used to perform we are
able to see
a more complete
analysis of those types of genes we have
uh
more than 400 genes we have 420 genes
that we are able to see the results and
for us it's a really good opportunity to
sequence those types of genes and to
have and to give a result to our samples
uh in a more broad
example when for us when we started the
validation and we started to perform
the analysis with those kids we have a
really good result analyzing
such uh for such
this amount of genes so
the panel designs demonstrate an
excellent coverage that results only 33
genes with a single axon level
resolutions we have more than
six thousand s in these indels and smvs
and it is really good for us because we
had
we had an expectation
when we started the test that uh maybe
the test won't be able to cover all the
smvs that we were looking for but uh by
the contrary we had a really good
opportunity to have in just one kit
the opportunity to analyze those the
genes the s and these the indels and the
cnb
uh
when we're talking about these types of
tests of course we do have special cases
uh genes and it is uh we have a lot of
genes that we must have
an extra
effort to increase the the coverage and
uh it was the the most challenging part
when we started a validation uh
with this panel because uh of course we
have a multi
disciplinary uh person that works at the
laboratory and
every single one has an opinion about
which type of ngs we are going to
perform and everything and of course we
do have uh
a fear that we are won't be able to see
some mutations or some variants in those
types of
challenging genes
in this panel it was really good because
this effort to increase the
the amplitum coverage to enable
potential single action in this uh 33
focus genes and say for instance the
ssdr the cystic fibrosis gene
and then we know that it's a really
difficult
gene to sequence we had a really good uh
opinion and we had a really good
experience in this battle we are able to
see in our validation
that the gene was covered really well
all the samples that we have
that unfortunately or or have the uh uh
any type of variant in this gene
we are able to see uh the result when
when we analyze uh in the the pipeline
uh of course we do uh we do stick with
uh all the samples that we perform in
our validation with the s5 uh sequencer
and
we had a really good opportunity to see
when we are we're looking at the carrier
report that is a software uh designed by
thermoscientific uh that we were able to
see an end-to-end
uh type of pro of of kit because we
receive
every single part of the key that we are
able to
to
to have the library to prepare the
library to to sequencing and of course
we do have the bioinformatics pipeline
that helps us to
to find out all the variants that were
we are looking for
so uh
in those slides we were talking about
the validation that thermal scientists
would perform and we are able to see the
smvs and intel call and we have an
accuracy of 99.5 the sensitivity about
100
and they're specifically
around 99.5
and in our validation in our own
validation we also see uh results
according to the same types of uh
thermal has found in this validation the
cmg calling we have a currency of 99.46
also what's good because uh we also in
our validation we also sequence uh
we already knew that those samples were
uh carrier positive samples and we have
around the same sensitivity and
specificity that thermal has in this
validation we have also in our
validation around 99
uh
in sensitivity and specifically uh when
we are talking about those those
positive those terror positive samples
the smvs was also
another challenging part of this type of
analysis because we all know that this
the snp calling thing when we sequence
it we have
some difficult some technical
difficulties but we do have a really
good concurrency when we perform the
test
with this panel we have a thermal has in
this validation a concordance of 100
percent
uh
as we said before uh the panel included
technically challenging genes associated
with several reference genes and
it was my opinion the most challenging
part of this validation for this panel
because we all know that for example
hpua1 and hp2 are really good really
difficult genes to sequence
we all know the sn1 sm1 that is a gene
that unfortunately called
spinal muscular atrophy that is a really
difficult gene to see the variant call
and to see the the gene carrier status
and
we have we can see it here in this uh in
this data that was provided by thermal
that we have a sensibility of or 100
and in our validation it was really a
really concerning part of it when we
we analyzed some
uh known smn gene kerry status and we do
have a really high
sensitivity for this type of genes
uh
they have achieved 100 sensitivity and
specificity for hp1 and hp2 in the
variant calling and 100 of concordancy
in the gba variant coding we do have uh
the same types of data and the same
types of rate in our own validation and
this is why we we started to perform the
analysis with this type of panel
it is
for us it was a really good opportunity
to see
to maximize
all the possibilities that we have
when we sequencing those types of uh
samples when we use the ngs to
analyze those types of positive samples
that we had
so uh to talk about a little bit uh in
this validation it is so important
because uh
thermal and also when we perform our
validation we also use the some some
corial samples uh
thermo used a 23 corial samples library
and uh as we all know the
na12878
one of the genomes most famous genomes
in every single one that works at
laboratory knows that genomes and knows
every single variant that has in this
genome uh thermal also use it and we
we also use it when we are we are
performing our validation and we can see
that this it has more than 99 percent uh
in intra in inter assay reproducibility
and it is really good for really good
when we are talking about those type of
samples
we can see
here in this slide that we have a
concurrency uh
more than
99.7 percent of smvs and indel
genotyping calls when we are using the
na12878
sample
in this uh validation uh two operators
each made a single library of this uh
this cell line and that was sequencing
in duplicate for a total of four tests
which showed a high analytical
sensitivity specificity and occur
accuracy across operator and library
the third part of this presentation
what are the best practices for the
implementation and the validation of the
kerosene
expanded carrier screen
so we have uh
key steps in the analytical validation
for this type of banner
and right now i'm gonna divide it in
three parts the test development
optimization the test validation and of
course one of the most important parts
the quality management
so
what are the activities when we when we
talk about the test development
optimization
we must
define the test definition and the
acceptable sample types
we must develop the variant calling and
the annotation pipeline
conduct a test performance assessment
based on the test definition
and develop a variant confirmation
strategy based on test performance and
at least
access the reference material and the
positive contrast for validation
and what are the outcomes for this type
for this part of this analytical
validation so we have the test
definition with variant class reported
established
we have the analytical pipeline
established
we have the performance metrics defined
the test limitations identified with
confirmation strategies developed and
the sample types
and number of samples that were that was
required
is required for a validation
to determine the term of validation
so when we think about the task
validation
we must have those types of activities
we must measure the test performance and
accuracy
with respect to
various class
varying size and the genomic context
we must measure reproducibility
we have
reproducibility and limits of detection
and of course
use of laboratory positive controls for
various class beyond the smvs and intel
in there this type of
in this part of the analytical
validation
we must have the outcome of a
documentation of every part of this test
validation
the test accuracy it is established for
all reportable variant classes
we have the reportable regions and the
test limitations documented
we have the performance metrics for
quality management plan
and the last part but not least the
quality management for this analytical
validation
we have to define metrics
for quality control monitoring of the
test performance
periodically
sequencing of positive controls and it
is so important to see the
reproducibility
of your
test of your kid
the quality assurance monitoring of the
test performance over time and it's so
important to always
keep an eye on monitoring the test
monitoring the types of variants that
you are looking in those types of
patterns
you have the outcome of a quality
control medical threshold for passing
the test established and a quality
control and assurance program
established it is so important
to have a quality
for all the samples that you're looking
to see
so
to have a conclusion in
this type of presentation
we have to think that the aim of the
test
is to identify couples in which both
parents are curious and
to prevent serious genetic disorders in
this their offspring it is
so important to think and to pass it
through uh this information
to
our um
our
colleagues and persons that we know that
it is so important that we have this
type of test to
analyze and to prevent serious genetic
disorders
the terror sect expanded carrier
screening kit
identify variants in hundreds of genes
across hundreds of samples with high
analytical sensitivity specificity and
the current accuracy across the cds and
target non-coding regions
of
420 genes
including
technically challenging targets
the kerastac kit is a research solution
that provides all reagents and material
for a comprehensive and flexible ngs
based expanded care screening workflow
and when you use it with the img studio
s5 system and the carrier reporter
software
the kit enables a sim a simple
end-to-end workflow for the detection of
carrier positive samples by research
labs interested in maximize the in this
identification of kerose status using
genome dna isolated from blood or saliva
sensors
i wanted to thank
all of you for being here and to see
this presentation and i wanted to thank
thermal fishing scientific in the united
states and of course the third official
here in brazil uh and i'll be able and
then and i'll be joining you guys to uh
a q a uh
part of right now if you have any doubts
any questions i'm more than welcome to
to reply you all thank you so much
thank you bruno for your informative
presentation before we start the live q
a portion of the webinar we have two
poll questions and encourage you to
participate
our first poll question is
i plan to bring carrier screening into
my lab and expect to have funds in
a 0 to 6 months
7 to 12 months
more than 12 months
or n a not applicable here for
information only
please click on your answer to this
question
i plan to bring carrier screening into
my lab and expect to have funds in
and please select your answer
okay
and then our next poll question
i am interested in learning more about
expanded carrier screening and ion
torrent carrier seek ecs
your options are
yes or no
please click on which ever answer
applies to you
give you just a few more seconds
make your choice
okay
well we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
in reference to your slide on analytical
validation
what was your analytical validation
experience like with carrier seek
well thank you so much for your question
uh
i had a really good opportunity to
perform the analytical validation and of
course thermal scientific here in brazil
helped with me with uh everything that i
could uh
perform to
have a good analytical validation here
in brazil so uh all the
all the technicians that works in
in thermal scientific help with me to to
analyze the samples to
choose which samples do we wanted to
sequence to help me to like everything
that we
we need in the in our our kids our
our
uh
everything that works with the kit so um
it's really good about this kit that we
can use uh
the kit for every single part so when we
receive the kit in our laboratory we
receive it everything so we receive
the
all the the parts for um
library prep to sequencing to to make
the template in the iron chef so
everything worked so smooth that it for
me was a really good experience to
perform this analytical validation
thank you
our next question is
what were the biggest challenges you
faced and how did you resolve them
well this is a really good question in
in my my opinion one of the biggest
challenge
was to really to have the confidence
that some challenging genes as we saw in
the presentation that really worked with
this uh with this daniel so
so everyone that works in a lab we have
some
these beliefs and we do think that some
genes we must have uh another type of
analysis that we must have some uh
some complemental analysis or performing
with another methodology and for us was
a really a really good part of the this
experience too
to see that we are able to see those
genes we selected some some samples that
were
positive for those uh for those
challenging genes and we were able to
see that we
found uh
we found the variants so it was really
uh really inspiring for us that we are
able to to analyze a lot of samples with
just one uh
with just one methodology and this is
why this was really really good for us
thank you
next question what is the sample size
for ngs based research panel validation
well um i can answer with what we
perform in our lab to have this
validation so we selected uh around 100
samples and of course we do selected the
in what ni 12 878 and also some samples
that we had in our lab to
that we have a positive control that we
knew the variants and everything but we
around 100 uh samples we we selected and
performed of course some of them were
positive some of them were negative
and we wanted to see if the panel could
uh check everything that we wanted and
we had a really good uh experience with
that
great
well it looks like we have time for one
more question can we use cord blood for
this experiment
well uh
we experienced uh
since we
when you have the dna extraction you can
analyze
any type of dna that you can have so uh
even a saliva kit swab or a blood
cord we can use it we you have to have a
really good dna extraction right so you
have
at least around uh for our experience
15 nanograms
of dna per microliter of course uh but
uh when you have when you have a good
dna uh
the dna quality or dna quantification
you're good to go and you can have uh
this panel to analyze every single
sample of it
thank you again bruno for your time
today
and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye
you